the international criminal court has now
issued an arrest warrant against
Russia's President Vladimir Putin
accusing him of being responsible for
war crimes committed in Ukraine while
our International Affairs editor Dominic
waghorn is here
um hi Dominic we know that President
Putin doesn't respect the jurisdiction
of the ICC so what does this actually
mean well I mean yes he's he's now
joining the list of a number of people
who've been indicted or about to be
indicted at least not exactly sure of
the exact status at the moment but there
is a long list of people who've been
indicted by the international criminal
court Omar al-Bashir the Sudanese leader
Gaddafi and his son seif on Islam were
both doing both indicted and unless the
war goes very badly for him he's toppled
from power and he's handed over it's
unlikely he's going to face trial
neither did Gaddafi or
yeah exactly so let's read out what that
says Mr Vladimir vladimirovich Putin
born on 7th of October 1952 president
the Russian Federation is allegedly
responsible for the war crime of
unlawful deportation of population of
children and that of the unlawful
transfer of population of children from
occupied areas of Ukraine to the Russian
Federation under and it lists various
articles the crimes were allegedly
committed in Ukrainian occupied
territory at least from the 24th of
February of last year there are
reasonable grounds it says to uh suspect
uh that uh he is responsible for a
number of crimes having committed the
acts directly jointly with others and or
through others and is guilty or
suspected for the failure to exercise
control properly over civilian and
Military subordinates who committed the
acts or allowed for their commission so
it's primarily about the Abduction of
children and interestingly in the same
statement from the ICC another person's
been mentioned and that is Maria Alex
who is the commissioner for children's
rights in the Office of the President of
the Russian Federation now so she's kind
of the the children's rights
commissioner in the Kremlin she has
gained notoriety because she has adopted
or claimed to have adopted a number of
Ukrainian children orphans some of whom
have been interviewed and she has wept
on Russian State television as she's
talked about the joy she's felt in
Saving these children and others see her
as being complicit in the abduction
kidnapping and deportation of these
children so she's a very controversial
figure and clearly she is alongside the
the president going to be a number of
amongst the suspects who are being
alleged to have been involved in the
Abduction of children and they're now
facing indictments in the international
crime Criminal Court
it's a very specific aspect isn't it
that they're going after here I mean
they've been calls for many
International bodies around the world to
um to make the act of aggression and
some so actually going into this war
invading Ukraine in the first place
making that a war crime what's the
latest on that there are a number of I
think legal Avenues being pursued by
human rights activists by various
International jurists by a number of
British human rights investigators and
they're focusing on the claims of war
crimes crimes against humanity and one
of the main Avenues is the is the idea
that he is pursuing genocide in Ukraine
because of course he doesn't accept
Ukraine has a right to exist and
therefore the war is in a sense in that
argument at least genocidal because it
is kind of denying the right of Ukraine
to exist and therefore of ukrainians too
exist those Avenues are being pursued
and evidence is being compiled and
gathered but nothing has got what's the
point yet amongst those lines of pursues
in terms of bringing charges or
indictment so this is the first
indictment of its kind that we're seeing
and as you say it's very specific it's
talking about the Abduction of children
saying there are reasonable grounds to
believe that Mr Putin Bears individual
criminal responsibility for these crimes
so it's saying that he is complicit he's
involved and directly involved
individually and not just him but also
this uh child's rights commissioner